be George Soros on globalization is the
investment managers look at promoting
democracy around the world by economic
means mr. Soros was interviewed about
his book recently by CNN's Jeff
Greenfield this event from the 92nd
Street Y in New York City is an hour in
20 minutes good evening my name is Debra
Nadel McGee I am the director of the
Charles Simon Center for adult life and
learning here at the 92nd Street Y
welcome to the last and of our three
evenings with Jeff Greenfield with Jeff
Greenfield for this season America and
the world 2002 Jeff has reported on
virtually every major political campaign
during his career his analysis of
contemporary events and his quick wit
has made him one of the most trusted
names in television journalism and he
can be seen on CNN at a number of
different times during the day so keep
watching Jeff tonight he will be in
conversation with George Soros the best
fund manager in history a stateless
statesman and one of the most original
thinkers of our time he is the founder
of a global network of foundations
dedicated to supporting open societies
following their conversation you will
have the opportunity to ask questions of
our guests please fill out the cards
that you were handed as you enter the
lecture hall and finally mr. Soros will
be signing copies of his groundbreaking
new book George Soros on globalization
in the art gallery right next door at
the end of the evening and the books are
for sale as you exit the hall and right
now it is both an honor and a pleasure
to once again welcome our very very dear
friend Jeff Greenfield thank you
get even aha they fixed it we we have
banded these programs together very
loosely under the September 11th rubric
and I think it's particularly
appropriate tonight with our final guest
of the series because the September 11th
taught us anything it's that the world
that the United States thought it was in
where the rest of the world could be
comfortably left behind
a world that posed no possible danger to
our peace or prosperity that world is
very much with us and that however you
look at what happened blind hatred or
cunning rage or grievances and
discontent left brewing that world was
going to be dealt with and had to be
dealt with at its roots nobody had to
tell George Soros this fact because for
the better part of 20 years he has been
at the business and I mean this
literally of changing the world trying
to change the world and make it freer
and fairer and better there's one
interesting measure of the man you were
about to meet the least interesting
thing I can tell you about him is that
he is one of the hundred or so richest
people in the world and this is a
society where as Bob Dylan once said
money doesn't talk it swears and where
we measure everything from movies to
athletes to potential candidates by the
size of their income or wealth or money
reasonability so this may seem like a
strange notion but not if you know
anything about the life and work and
thinking of George Soros if you tried to
present his life as a movie plot the
most credulous producer would say come
on that's ridiculous at age fourteen
hiding on pain of death from Nazis and
their collaborators in Budapest at 17
confronting the Soviet invasion of his
homeland leaving for England existing on
menial jobs and help not entirely
authorised by various agencies
developing a passion for philosophy at
26 coming to America with the notion of
staying here just long enough to get a
Nesta
so he could go back to England and spend
his life studying philosophy a career on
Wall Street always somehow ahead of the
curve and risking increasingly large
amounts on stocks bonds currencies
ultimately out dueling Her Majesty's
Government on a bet that the British
Pound would fall that netted him and his
allies in a day a billion dollars let me
put it this way if you've given Soros a
hundred thousand bucks in 1969 and left
it there by 1960 by 1997 he'd have had
about three hundred and fifty million
dollars that's the least interesting
factor because slowly somehow George
Soros decided that what he really wanted
to do was to give his money away but not
to establish charities but in fledgling
efforts literally around the world to
change society to try to figure out how
to plant the seeds of alternative
institutions in very repressive places
to nurture the open society of which
he's talked and written so much his
efforts now are literally cradle to the
grave and beyond from a Russian
headstart program to a University in
Budapest to a study of American
attitudes toward death he is out to
reform us drug laws he's out to Train
lawyers in the former Soviet Union he's
out to battle TB in the third world and
in some 50 nations he's busily giving
away each year about a half a billion
dollars of his fortune and all the while
he is pushing and badgering nations and
institutions like the International
Monetary Fund of the World Bank to go
headlong at global poverty itself just
one of the topics that is covered in his
new book on globalization he has been
called everything from a revolutionary
plutocrat to the one man with his own
foreign policy and the means to
implement it two failed philosopher
that's his term for himself so ladies
and gentlemen please welcome failed
philosopher George Soros
I told mr. Soros that we needed to put
these microphones very close to our lips
and it turns out he and I and oh I guess
about 70% of you share a hearing issue
so we're gonna try not spend the entire
being saying to each other what is this
good for you it's very good okay I want
to spend most of tonight talking about
your ideas and what you've done but I
think a little background is in order
your father was a devotee of Esperanto
the International language that was
invented in part to bring nations
together the question I have about this
is since part of your thinking is a bit
about what we as human beings are like
do you think that in some sense that
indicates that what you spend the rest
of your life on is hardwired in other
words do you think there's a certain
genetic thing in the DNA that says in
one way or another you were gonna wind
up trying to change the world you know I
don't think its genetic but I think it
definitely is my father's influence I
mean he has really had a great he really
helped for me and now of course my
mother also had a great influence on me
and I loved them both and they were very
often at loggerheads with each other so
this created a kind of a very strange
internal conflict inside me which it
took me practically my whole life to
work out I can't imagine anyone this
audience identifying with the clash
between a mother and a father
unknown to most of us there's a more
serious part of your early background
and again I want to explore whether or
not you think it had an impact it's
often been instead of you that in your
in your life when you were accumulating
the money you as they say in poker would
often put in the whole stack the bets
that you made were extremely out there
on the yen on real estate investment
trusts on the pound and at least some
people have suggested that if you at age
fourteen are literally risking death if
you are found out that the person your
documents say you are isn't if your
whole family is at risk that if that's
how you grow up taking chances kind of
comes a little easier than it might be
to somebody raised comfortably you think
that's right so if again I think it
definitely had a great influence that
experience of hiding from from the Nazis
and the the danger I think that I kind
of learned how to handle a danger and I
also was quite fascinated by it so I
like to push to the limit but I
certainly don't like to push over the
limit so it's aggression of how far can
you push and still come out hole so I
think this is an essential element in
risk-taking there are many people who
don't like to take risks and there are
people who take too much risk and
actually get swept away and
sort of overstate this side of that
particular divide well I asked because
in politics it's interesting to me that
many of the politicians who are most
comfortable with themselves and are
prepared to kind of challenge the
conventions like John McCain like a
couple of the senators who were at
action in Vietnam are people who faced
real risk when they were young and so
for them the idea of taking on a
political machine well you know if
you're John McCain you spend five years
in the North Vietnamese prison camp not
so big a deal yeah I think that is true
of John McCain they're just a couple of
other areas about about tough enough a
couple of other areas about what may
have helped form you when the war ended
and we're talking now about a I guess a
15 or a 16 year old you practiced your
trading skills I guess it's fair to say
if not on the black market than a gray
market you were but actually I started
earlier because I did it in 44 because
my father used me as a kind of runner to
execute currency transactions and and
and gold because being 13 14 I was less
subject to being stopped so actually I
got a pretty early training in that even
better do you think that as you went
into Wall Street and we're dealing in
hundred million dollar and billion
dollar Gamble's being serious business
did anything from those formative years
stay with you did it have any impact or
is that just some some romantic notion
that we can dismiss no I mean basically
most of my life I have not thought about
what happened in those I put it behind
me but certainly I'd learned a certain
ways of of acting and particularly I
learned from my father
you know how to take a stand when to
take a stand but not to take a stand so
that was the formative experience of my
life now when I used to tell people many
years ago that I was a philosophy major
people said to me what a brilliant
vocational choice did you know you're
really headed right for a career aren't
you
and I had no answer to that that you do
you think that there was any part about
your lifelong passion to think about to
write philosophy to think about your
mentor Karl Popper that actually served
you particularly in being able to be as
successful as you are on Wall Street yes
I may not have been able to communicate
my philosophy or explain it but it has
certainly guided me and it has guided me
both in making money and in spending it
so it has been the the connecting link
between those two aspects of my
existence now if this were a television
program I'd say well in 30 seconds could
you explain that life's philosophy and
how it affected your business so I won't
ask you to do it in 30 but in what sense
did it did it help
well the basically the problem that I
was trying to resolve is the problem of
a thinking participant that is when you
are thinking you try to understand but
when you are participating you change
the the situation in which you
participate so how can you gain
knowledge in the definition of truth
correspondence theory of truth a
statement is true if it corresponds to
the facts now in being a thinking
participant you are not dealing with
facts because your actions change what
you think about and this is the
conundrum that we all
now we haven't really quite drawn the
conclusions from this year stating it
like this it's it's one sort of more or
less commonplace but for every sense it
means that there is a difference between
the social sciences and and the natural
sciences because in Natural Sciences you
are actually dealing with facts so for
instance my theory of reflexivity it's
very similar to Heisenberg's theory of
our principle of uncertainty but the
behavior of atoms or particles doesn't
change when Heisenberg pronounces his
theory of or principle of uncertainty
whereas our society or our life changes
depending on what theories behold so
there is an additional element of
uncertainty in Social Affairs and it in
part it seems to have been your gift to
be able to have seen that at work in
markets I mean even seeing that at times
to be able to say all right everybody
thinks this is a rational process these
stocks are being valued in some perfect
marketplace but this there's an
uncertainty going on if there's or
irrationality or so on it's it's it's
quite it would be irrational to follow
the principle of rational expectations
because of this uncertainty and
certainly at the time and I started in
business you had the Aves of a
prevailing dogma which you know rational
expectations markets tending towards
equilibrium and so on so at that time I
think I was a little bit ahead of the
by recognizing the uncertainty I want to
say one more one area on the world of
finance because back in the late 60s
when conglomerates were all the rage you
said early that you thought there was a
kind of a I don't know if you used the
word bubble but it was that idea that
there was a kind of a if I may use this
term irrational exuberance right about
the feeling that well if it's the
conglomerate it's gonna be great and
getting out early was a big help
alright now we fast-forward 30 something
years to the dot-com boom same thing it
was the same thing that the important
thing to to understand about it is that
it actually changes reality in other
words it isn't just that there is
irrational exuberance
but that exuberance actually changes it
can justify itself for an extended
period of time so you have a an
initially self-reinforcing but
eventually unsustainable and
self-defeating process and that is more
characteristic of financial markets than
equilibrium so and not only of financial
markets but also of history in general
so that just on the financial market
thing for a while if somebody calls
themself Jeff Greenfield calm and I have
no profit plan and no business plan I'm
still gonna get people to buy two
billion dollars worth of stock for a
while until they see that I'm walking on
air right yeah but but they it has
actually you know changed for me for
instance it has that led to the very
rapid introduction of of Internet it
couldn't have grown as fast if it hadn't
been for the height so now for instance
you have the the other side of it and
and with for instance the Enron scandal
and and a number of other things that
are happening are the the negative
aspects of that boom-bust let me now
make a bridge between the first part of
your career and where we are where
you've been for the last well because
there's something interesting that you
that you said and I kind of alluded to
it and introducing you you say you said
there is a tendency in our society to
exaggerate the importance of money and
so I'm wondering to what extent you
think your ideas about the international
community about reform about all the
things you're involved in got a better
hearing as you accumulated great sums of
money that people assume well he's got
to know what he's talking about here
because look at all the money he's made
yeah absolutely I mean since I haven't
been terribly successful in let's say
expounding my philosophy as such the
fact that I have a platform is entirely
due to the fact that I've made a few
billion dollars
I'm saying I get that but I cannot
forbear pointing out that if Donald
Trump had tried to do what you did I'm
not sure all his money would have made
much difference but the limit isn't
there well that's true and also I should
point out that that in a way finance of
the financial markets served as a
laboratory for testing my ideas so I
think the fact that that I've been
successful at least sets up some that's
a justification for thinking that there
is something in those ideas that they
are not all nonsense now one of the
things and I don't know if I'm reading
this your history right and I have a
feeling you'll tell me if I'm not but
it's interesting to me that many of the
things you first got involved in it seem
to be you'd look at it you looked at a
closed society and you saw signs that
the ice was cracking and that's when
they moved 1979 the first signs that
maybe in South Africa something may be
changing they want to admit blacks to
the University of Cape Town black
students have no money you say okay I'll
pay their room and board you see in
Hungary that the authorities are kind of
letting economists have a free flow of
information you say all right let's send
them a lot of books let's send them a
bunch of Xerox copiers to increase the
flow of information
you see Gorbachev in the Soviet Union
inviting Sakharov back to Moscow you say
this you know is it correct to say that
that that that is a key to what what
you're doing that you needed to see some
sign of an opening and a previously
closed society to see now I can move
yeah basically I look at history the
same way as I look at financial markets
and in fact I think of financial markets
as a historical process in there was
that they are not really tending towards
equilibrium they never go back to where
they came from they always move forward
in is
way and the same is true of of history
so I think that and there are certain
signs that I look for in financial
markets to indicate that there is what I
call a reflexive process in in the
making and the same applies to go to
history and certainly I could see a an
opening in the in the Soviet system and
in fact I sort of interpreted it as a
boom past a kind of sequence which was
approaching the bust but by an and the
and when I started first in set up my
first foundation in Hungary in 84 that
was during the communist regime and my
concept was that the Communist Dogma is
false and if you can show an alternative
if you expose it to any kind of
alternative it will its falsehood will
become more apparent therefore if you
support anything that is not official a
state and party operation but just
empower people to to do the things that
they want to do then the system will
crumble to the very simple very abstract
idea and it worked but it it's
interesting to me that when China seemed
to be opening and I think what you've
described can be shown perfectly by the
fact that among other things that your
foundations or organization sponsored
war for instance an attempt to find folk
art and music that had been suppressed
during the Cultural Revolution that
would be an indication of an attempt to
say alright anything that isn't this
official Dogma will help but it
ultimately in China it didn't at least
not yet it hasn't yet cracked because
it's at least as I read the history the
folks in charge
they may be letting go economically but
they're not letting go politically or
culturally well I set up took that idea
to China
that's the same idea that I had in
Hungary in 84 I took to China in 87 and
I set up a foundation there and while
the foundation in Hungary succeeded the
foundation in China failed because the
idea that I brought there was actually
an alien idea for the Chinese they have
a certain mentality which I call the
feudalism of the mind and that is that
they they have a certain allegiance to a
group and they don't have the same
tradition of in the freedom and
independence that we have so I took that
alien idea there and it failed and I
recognized that it was my fault in not
understanding you know how China is
different from from us you know this
raises a question that I've been asking
as many people as I can and it seems
like it's a it's an interesting one to
put on the table for you because it
relates to where we're going next which
is this whole war on terrorism not a new
better if you'd looked at Nazi Germany
and Tojo and Hirohito's Japan when we
were fighting with them you would not
have seen many signs of an open society
and yet five years after the end of
World War two roughly five years both of
those societies were open stable
democratic and allied with the west and
what some people but some people have
raised about this is the idea that says
well you know what what does that teach
us that you can take alien hostile
ideologies that don't have no contact
with freedom and if you defeat them
soundly enough
and occupy them and our beneficent you
can turn them around very quickly so
anything to that well I think that that
well certainly what you say is right but
I think that for instance Japan has many
features it still does that don't make
it entirely an open society and in fact
Japan got into a lot a lot of trouble
when it opened up its financial system
it it had a very good well-functioning
financial system as long as it was
closed as long as there were no no
alternatives then when it was opened up
it effectively collapsed and China today
a face is the same problem I went back
to China after twelve years just just
recently and I had some meetings that
was sort of how I say really established
good cordial relations David and and
this was the point that I was trying to
to bring home to the to the Chinese
leadership that joining the World Trade
Organization they are taking a
tremendous risk and to prepare for that
risk
they have really got to move towards
greater freedom of speech freedom of
information even political freedom
because otherwise they they will
actually get into very serious
difficulty are they listening to you
honest do they believe you well we had a
good conversation and and at the end
and they said you know this is very
interesting but let's get back to the
financial markets here's what I'm
getting at you were about trying to
calculate but ten or ten or twelve days
ago let's say two weeks who gave up gave
us a speech you call it a conversation
okay in which you were very critical
about the Bush administration and its
post September 11th wine and and this is
what I want to push you on you said how
can we escape from the trap the
terrorists a set us only by recognizing
that the war on terrorism cannot be won
by waging war we must of course protect
our security but we must also correct
the grievances on which terrorism feeds
now the counter-argument that some in
the Bush administration and some
thinkers would argue is wait a second if
you look at what we did in Germany in
Japan first we beat the hell out of them
and then their societies will reform so
that this they would argue is typical
woolly-headed international thinking you
know we have got to use overwhelming
force change the regimes that are
spreading this terrorism if necessary
and that's the way to long term peace to
which you would say well to which I
would say that that you have got to
defend yourself against terrorism in
other words you can't ignore it or not
react to it but if you think that you
can defeat terrorism by using
overwhelming force then I think you are
actually doing what the terrorists want
you to do because by applying
overwhelming force you then generate
further resentment and there is a a sort
of a pattern that that would actually
feed that
so I think this war and terrorism
actually reminds me of the war on drugs
it's the it's the same sort of thing
there is a problem drug abuse that's a
problem you have to deal with it but you
can't have a drug-free America and you
can't have a world without without
terrorists but what the effect of the
terrorists have whether they have
followers you see that depends on how
people feel whether they are they have
grievances that the terrorists can play
off or whether they basically content
and therefore they don't sympathize with
the terrorists I mean we need in order
to do - let's say discover terrorists
and then locate them we need cooperation
we need people who will inform on them
because they don't like what they're
doing
so this idea of war on terrorism is a
false metaphor and a false metaphor can
do tremendous damage let's take a let's
let's look at this and let me offer you
a different counter-argument this notion
that if we that with without dealing
with the grievances I know you're not
saying on one on one but if we don't
deal with the grievances that we'll
never win now let me make the argument
that what you may be ignoring here is
something very dark and deep in human
nature
for instance Yugoslavia Serbia was a
first world country certainly in
relative terms quite prosperous and yet
slobodan milosevic in the late 1980s was
able to rise to power by feeding
grievances not about education income
but a 500 year old battle
Kosovo that the Serbs had been
humiliated by their enemies it was time
for vengeance and you got the presidency
of Serbia by that wound up killing this
tens of thousands of people Osama bin
Laden has never talked about the
grievances in terms of black have
education poverty most of which have
been imposed by the Muslim rulers of
these country he's still an e still
angry that the Moors were driven out of
Spain by Ferdinand and Isabella in 1492
and my point is isn't this notion of
going to the root causes and that's how
we're going and fix it ignoring this
whole other dimension of human beings in
our response to these kinds of you're
right in in what you say about bin Laden
or and terrorists in in general
therefore you can't cure terrorism by
going to the root causes either you know
worse you can't let's say deal with
Milosevic sometimes you actually have to
go to war I was very much in favor of of
intervening in Yugoslavia so it's not an
either/or situation I think that there
is a false metaphor involved about
waging war and terrorists as opposed to
waging war on velocities because we lost
which represented a state as an army you
could deal with it in in that way
whereas terrorism is something else but
the point I would make is that you have
got to have it a two pronged approach so
the fact that I I said that the ought to
address the root causes doesn't mean
that we should not stand up to terrorism
in this I promise audiences saying when
are you going to ask you and I will
we're gonna turn to the Middle East at
some point I promise you because it has
such implications but I want to I want
to stay for a bit about this pretty
tough criticism you made about the Bush
administration I take it your your
fundamental argument really is that they
just don't they're they're just too
indifferent to the rest of the world
look I think that we have to recognize
that we are the most powerful nation in
the world today we have our our economic
financial power our military power is
unparalleled now we are in fact the
dominant power in the global capitalist
system we are in a position to address
the shortcomings of the system and only
we are in a position to do so because we
have that leadership position we can't
it's not that we can do anything we want
but basically nothing can happen without
our cooperation in the way of anything
to do with international arrangements
international laws international
institutions we have a veto in the case
of the United Nations of course there
are others who have a veto in the
monetary field nobody else has to be
direct except us and I think that we are
missing
we are misusing our power by trying to
gather more power and projecting that
power and a dominant one thing to
dominate because that causes resentment
I think we are successful enough that we
ought to devote more of our resources
and more of our attention to making the
world a better place now that's where I
want to not turn but but before I do I
just need to know what the implications
of what you've been saying about
terrorism how you fight it what
implications you draw for the if any for
the Koren
Middle East I don't even know the Krait
to use upheaval crisis someone seems too
easy to 2-mile but what so if for
instance if the Israelis say look that's
all well and good the Palestinians need
a state they've got to have a sense of
but you know as long as they and their
leaders and half of the Arab states as
long as their real goal is the
extermination of Israel we got a problem
here before we get to step B yeah well
the you there is a genuine legitimate
grievance of the Palestinians that
Israel has failed to address these these
refugee settlements have been there for
50 years so and actually there was a
very courageous attempt to bring about
peace by Rubin it came awfully close to
close to success so close you know Iraq
I'm talking about Rabine because he that
was really when there was really a kind
of a sense of reconciliation as well as
just a settlement it was a kind of an
emotional breakthrough at the time and
they were extremists on the Israeli side
who did not want a settlement and Rabine
was killed by Israeli extremists
similarly I am very critical of the
Charan government's
policies now that doesn't mean that I'm
condoning arafat or or think that he is
right in what he is doing but I think
both sides are now dominated by
extremists and there is a certain sort
of boom-bust kind of self reinforcing
process where there's a victim who
becomes perpetrator who then called it
creates more of a sense of injustice
which then feeds on itself and this is a
really a race to the bottom and there is
this element in my view in in in the
Middle East today and I think that is a
terrifying example for us in the United
States to contemplate because I think we
have got people similar to our Father
and Chiron in our government today and
and you know it's not so not polite to
name names but but you know you know I
think Cheney Rumsfeld Ashcroft have the
same mindset
let me just revisit this because again
this is this is not far from the hearts
of many people their understanding what
you have said understanding that Ariel
Sharon is not Rabine is not Barack if
the other side's fundamental problem is
that they want to see the State of
Israel as a Jewish state eliminated I
don't necessarily mean the people I mean
one of the one of the Hamas said oh no
you know they Jews can stay here as long
as they're willing to live in an Islamic
state of Palestine if that first hurdle
isn't clearly cleared as Sadat cleared
it back in the 70s as Jordan did in the
I guess the early 90s maybe earlier if
that isn't clear how does anything I
mean I know what people out there some
people that they're gonna say to you is
that you're a moral equivalency guy you
can't see the difference between one
state that's got flaws it's Democratic
but it's got flaws it's got bad leaders
it isn't and these are the guys who
simply want this other state to go away
look clearly you need you need you need
you need an Israeli state that that is
secure you also need a Palestinian state
so you need you need both and and I
think that you need both sides to
recognize that now let's say Saudi
Arabia made a gesture about recognizing
Israel as a state of course it was a
little bit of a you know there's a
little twist to it because you still
have the problem of refugees returning
and you can't have it both ways
in other words you can if you have if
you have divided a country into two
states Israel and Palestine they've
clearly clearly the Arabs can only
return to Palestine and not to Israel so
actually the solution to the problem is
is is obvious you know it's two states
is side-by-side right now they have to
be very captive part because of the
tremendous animosity and and that has
been built up but they do have to live
side by side now there are elements on
both sides that don't want to get there
and they are successful okay
I want to move to a little bit toward
toward the broader issues of
globalization and some of the things
that you have you have said about this
it's interesting that you know at this
point now every time there is a
conference of financial movers and
shakers of I'm sure you're at all of
these you know or invited at all them
just a few of them okay its World Trade
Organization it's Seattle it's Italy
it's the Waldorf forever and there are
there are great numbers of people who
are fundamental who fundamentally have
argued that globalization in and of
itself is responsible for increasing
inequality and decreasing opportunity
for the poor of the world so let's talk
about a couple of these things first is
globalization as you see it in
inevitable and well let's start there is
it's happened and that's it and then
that's irreversible no I don't think
it's irreversible it has happened before
and it has been reversed before because
you had basically very similar
conditions in the late 19th century I
mean I define globalization in a very
narrow sense to me
globalization is the globalization of
financial markets the fact that capital
can move wherever it wants to freely and
that is a relatively new development in
the current stage I mean we've been you
know moving towards globalization since
the Second World War but I would say
that is really only since 1980 when you
had Reagan in the United States and
Margaret Thatcher in
in England that financial markets became
truly global now that has some very
positive effects and some negative ones
because capital can move around freely
it means that it can't be regulated or
text as easy as easily as it could
before now a capital and a private
enterprise is very good at creating
wealth so liberating capital in this way
has I think accelerated wealth creation
creation of private wealth but markets
are not designed to provide public goods
that is was that is the task of the
state or in this globalized world do you
actually need some international
arrangements and that is what is missing
from globalization it's a lopsided
development let me be very let me see if
I can get very specific about where you
where what you want to see happen the
classic example countries like the
United States has labor laws health and
safety laws minimum wage laws capital
now can flee you don't have to make the
sneakers in the United States you make
them in Bangladesh and you you know and
with with virtually let's say no
regulation at all about wages safety
anything right what's to be done about
that well that is a very difficult
problem you all want you know yeah you
know you don't want an easy question
you know and I don't have sort of a
30-second answer to it either I've you
know sort of examined the various
institutions we have we don't have
similarly effective organizations for
protecting labor for instance so today a
China is a in an inexhaustible source of
cheap labor whose efficiency is
improving by leaps and bounds but there
is no freedom of association so the the
Chinese workers it can't get their share
of the improved of the increased
efficiency and that needs a
strengthening of the International Labor
Organization ILO now interestingly the
ILO has a very similar structure to the
WTO it it has the ability to impose
sanctions similar to the WTO the only
problem is that people haven't the
countries haven't actually subscribed to
the to the covenants of the ILO there
are 67 covenants let's here and the
United States has registered two of them
and of course China has has registered
none so I think you need to strengthen
the international labor organization
okay
now I'm sure this sounds you know
protectionist or retro but what would be
from your point of view what would be
the problem with the United States by
legislation saying to these companies
almost all of them want to deal in the
American market if your goods are made
under those circumstances under those
conditions you can't bring them into the
United States and seller clearly an
interference with movement of CAP
but on the other hand what's what's
wrong with that the only thing wrong
with it is that it would destroy the WTO
regime in order to destroy free trade
because according to the rules of the
WTO that doesn't come into account
you're not allowed to use slave labor
that there's a rule against that
but there is no rule against against
cheap labor and and in effect if you can
produce cheaper in other countries you
both sides benefit I mean the
international trade does benefit both
both sides where the deficiency is is on
the political side that in China if
anybody tries to organize the workers
the hands up in there in prison and
that's where the the deficiency is do
you believe as some people do that if
that it is that if a regime opens itself
up economically it is in effect going to
have to open up politically that is I
mean people think that to some extent
that happen in Hungary they tried to
open up politically I mean economically
the economists and business people said
you gotta let us have more information
and and it was inevitable do you think
it's inevitable that a country that
liberalizes economically even one like
China well sooner or later find itself
whatever it wanted to do becoming free
politically and not at all not at all
because people who the the rulers don't
actually like to abdicate their rules so
they do need to be pushed before they
change
and of course they have to be pushed
internally but they also have to be
pushed externally and and in fact most
of my efforts have been devoted to
strengthening the demands internally for
for freedom open society you were and
you've been you were very successful I
think some people would say surprisingly
so back in the in the late 70s and in
the 80s particularly in going to
societies that weren't free and say well
open up a little bit you know let us
we'll work with you we'll work with it
happening hungry it happened in the old
Soviet mean to some extent do you think
that that kind of approach could work in
let's say the Muslim world which has
never been through any kind of modernity
they've they've you know there's no real
even economic development in other words
is what worked for you and hungry what
you tried in China what worked in the
Soviet Union what worked in the didn't
work in China and of course it probably
wouldn't work in in in Islamic countries
but it's very interesting I've met with
some human rights activists in actually
in Lebanon and this man said you know we
really have no space for civil society
the the Western powers deal with the
government they want they want because
they are interested in resources or in
some geopolitical considerations they
have not been at all supportive of civil
society the only place where you can
express your disagreement with the
regime which we consider an imposition
an oppressive regime is in the mosque
there you can speak the under the
umbrella of religious expression so
opposition has gathered in the mosque
the same way as in in in Poland the
opposition found an umbrella under the
Catholic Church so it we are I mean it's
not that it would really change things
dramatically or that you could you could
sort of suddenly move over to but we
have been very neglectful of the
internal conditions that prevail in
these countries because we have been
interested in the natural resources and
it's the rulers who have the title and
so we have been dealing with them and we
have ignored what they do internally but
if if the kind of messages that are that
are being delivered in the mosques in
some of these countries arts are not
exactly the same messages that were
being delivered in the churches of
Poland right I mean quite the contrary
with that part of their argument is that
their rulers are in bombing tel aviv
right now so my guess my question is if
if there were thirty younger i don't
have to be younger tree 30 2015 george
soros is out there with a great deal of
capital and a willingness to spend that
in creative ways as you did and they
said we really want to see if we can
begin to help change or create open
societies in the muslim world
is there anything concrete you could
tell them to do now well i think that
particularly the role of women in in
Muslim
the society's is a sort of a nope that
is an area where there is room for
opening because it is sort of
penetrating into these societies that
that there's an init inequality between
in the in the position of women so I
think there is room for a women's
movement in in these countries which
could move the countries in in in the
direction of open society but I mean if
you take a country like like Egypt there
are a lot of people who are not happy
with the with the regime who are not
Muslim fundamentalist and they or they
also have no room to express themselves
now of course the problem is that most
of the people in those countries if they
were free to express themselves would
turn towards Islamic fundamentalism in
in Algeria for instance they were about
to win the elections when the military
intervened now in my opinion if they had
been allowed to win today Algeria would
be right for democracy in the same way
as Iran where the the religious
extremism to power there is a very
strong movement for open society are you
involved no I'm not involved in and I
think it would be very dangerous but I'm
aware of what's going on and I read
there are
our Muslim clerics that are quoting a
car Papa and go to jail I'm going to
turn through the audience questions
which look pretty interesting but I do
up before we do fund I don't mean
fundamentally in the Islamic sense but a
troop let's say the work you've done
very creative
far more flexible than government
foreign aid as we think about it
we've got people like Bill Gates come in
with the Gates Foundation I think it's a
seventeen billion dollar endowment do
you believe that individuals with that
kind of resource cons of resources and
the willingness to be creative
can change the world more than
governments and international
institutions or is a to bigger job to
just be left individuals no matter how
much money they have I I think that we
can make a contribution and we can show
the way but I think you need
governmental resources to back it up I
mean I you know I'm spending a half a
billion dollars a year the the what you
need for the Millenium targets is fifty
billion and $1 so but I think where we
can be helpful is in let's say making be
the the aid more effective because the
trouble is a lot of it has been actually
counterproductive because the the aid is
designed to serve the interests of the
donors first and the recipients a second
I think what why I have been to the
extent that I have been successful is
because I actually have no ax to grind
I let the people in the country decide
their priorities and I think if we did
the same with with our official
development assistance it would actually
be much more effective footnote to this
do you like the the notion of the the
very small scale efforts like the micro
banks were they lends a $25 to an Indian
woman to buy a sewing machine and then
she gets she becomes self-sufficient and
then they pay the loans but it's not
it's something that I think works it has
been shown to work I think it needs to
be scaled up
and for that you see you need you need
something more than what is happening
today and that would be one of the
things that I would do is to to create
the the infrastructure that would make
it on a much larger scale okay your
questions these these are a wide range
which we always get this is a nice easy
one who was the greatest world leader of
the past 30 years
well whom do I admire I would say
sakarov was the man who whom I really
admired hundred because of his moral
sense not that he he was a success he
was not successful but you know in order
to when you stand for something you have
to fight losing battles and and he was
one of those as you recall and I'm gonna
I know I'm gonna mispronounce this name
this is a question about the head of
Malaysia's dr. metier Maha did not hear
left out of our but
as you recall dr. metier I'm sure you
recall this blame you for the economic
problems of Malaysia when there they
collapsed the CEO he made some pretty
sharp anti-semitic remarks hmm so first
what are you doing to reduce the anti
Semitic plague in the world and what are
you doing for Israel do you feel any
responsibility to act in these areas as
though well I've always regarded
anti-semitism as a kind of a meta
problem in other words is something that
you can't I can't really deal with
directly but indirectly in other words
in a way I feel that I'm fighting
anti-semitism by promoting an open
society that's you know indirectly
related to it and as for the second part
of the question that Israel you have any
involvement in Israel they should work
there very little III have actually
supported a media center in Palestine
which was a critical of Arafat now
unfortunately that media center has now
been destroyed
but I thought that was an important
thing to help the palace Palestinian
state to develop into an open society
and not dominated by people who want to
destroy Israel what do you think of the
anti-globalization demonstration
demonstration so they help the poor or
hurt the poor I think that they were
actually helpful in drawing attention
the attention of the authorities and the
elites that there is something wrong I
think that they their their thrust was
misdirected because it's that it was
directed at the international
institutions that we have whereas really
most of the misery and poverty in the
world today is due to bad government bad
government in less developed countries
that's why the one of the reasons why
they are less developed do you agree
with the man whose name of course at
this age I have forgotten there's a
Nobel laureate an Indian who argues that
I'm HSN yeah that democracy is a great
antidote to progress
he says development as freedom and I
subscribed to that I only interviewed
him a couple of years ago so we better
finish this interview fast before I
decide that I'm interviewing the manager
of the New York Yankees
the cup they're a couple of these
questions are unavoidable but they're
not they're not differently what's your
favorite thing to spend money on or and
it is a different question what do you
do for fun
mm-hmm well first of all I like to do
some sports I play tennis ski and so on
and I like to read and I like to have a
good discussion
you don't need billions of dollars to
you this is not the same question but
it's the question here I love this this
is why I like this do you do well at the
racetrack too
and the point about that question is
does it all boil down to being a superb
gambler and isn't that a gift now before
you shake your head in this biography of
yours that I read both your son and a
long-term acquaintance have said this
about you they said he thinks it's a
science but it's not it's this intuitive
art he can his body you get back spasms
when you feel something coming is that
true but that is true but that wouldn't
that wouldn't help you at the racetrack
okay
but I guess the question is at some
point doesn't it come down whether it's
whether it's like you know good-looking
three-year-old Delmont or that
questionable new North Area store that
you get some point you just have to say
I'm going well I think that is it's
preferable to bet when you have an edge
when you know you think you know
something that the others don't
now you may have that knowledge in the
racetrack and some people do but I don't
why shouldn't the heads of Enron and
Arthur Andersen be jailed for twenty
years
yeah look I think that that has been a
definite access they misused the the
rules that that prevail and they are
responsible I'm particularly critical of
the auditing profession I was just
reading an article in The New Yorker
describing the the the fact that they
were lobbying they were fighting with
the SEC in the international level
trying to separate and that is you see I
think that as long as you play by the
rules that's fine but when you bend the
rules and particularly when you fix the
rules and and
use your clout your financial clout to
introduce or abolish regulations and so
that's where we are going wrong the
second part of this question I didn't
leave it out China leads the way in
punishing white-collar crime what is
your opinion
well I'm somewhat critical of the
Chinese judiciary system you know as
they they execute people a little bit
too to feelings and and it's very
interesting I had very good discussion
about this in China they are now moving
to establish genuine legal system for
commercial law but they are very far
from using those principles for in
criminal law that's the quote I think
that's the heart of this question is
that apparently what you're saying and
this is that at least in China they
really think they can just split this
difference that they can be an open and
economic society or more open in a
closed political system yes yes now this
is a nice easy one okay what is your
outlook for the global geopolitical
economic trends in the next five 200
years
I would say mix I actually think that we
are we have a choice and we can make
this global system work by addressing
the shortcomings or is going to collapse
as it collapsed before and it will
collapse politically in other political
developments and since the United States
is the linchpin
we are the imperial power in the world
today it's up to us which way we go and
the the the the trouble is that we don't
have the vision or the sense of
responsibility that goes with our
position and we don't have the
leadership I'm very critical of the Bush
administration but I'm also very
critical of the Democrats because they
don't offer an alternative vision so the
way we are going I don't think the
system will last because if the people
if the participants don't benefit from
it it's basically an unstable system but
you know maybe it's because I'm in the
middle of this of two different books
one is this Robert Caro biography of
Lyndon Johnson we're now roughly about
fifty years ago and sometime in the next
200 years he's gonna get to the
presidency and another book is about
Cicero that's about 2,000 years ago and
I come away with these books very
depressed because and maybe I shouldn't
be because you just it's the same damn
thing over and over it's greed and it's
shortsightedness and it's appealing for
políticas pandering for political gain
for the you know for the shortest term
goal and as far as I can tell and you
may have a different example except for
the years after World War two this
country has never been really this is
the United States forget wrong for a
minute
and she's never very think about taking
on an international responsibility with
vision so yeah but you know it's a
relatively new position for us to be in
we've had very strong principles of
freedom internally with the Constitution
the Bill of Rights and so on but it's
only in the last 50 years that we have
become the leading power in the world
now in that respect we are now occupying
a position similar to Britain in in the
19th century and we have to somehow live
up to that responsibility so I think
it's we have reason to worry it with the
way we are going about it but I don't
think it's a reason to give up hope
because I think it's it's possible that
we actually you know change our attitude
and I think we really need to work and a
change of heart in the United States
this is an interesting one how do you
measure the success of your foundations
and your efforts I mean I guess now 50
countries now there have been times but
you've looked at something said I rolled
it up right didn't work yeah there is
actually no reliable objective criterion
and by which to judge it is different
from making money because making money
you've got the bottom line and here
you've got a
a great number of lines have you affect
different people in a society and you
can't add it up because there are
different people and different interests
so in the end it's really a hunch and
and one has to be very much aware of the
unintended consequences of what you do
and the first rule is try to do no harm
there a few more I'm going to get to
before but I need to interject one
question here that's that I just wonder
about it would seem to me that one of
the permanent conditions of your efforts
is that every so often and maybe it's
more than a result and somebody's gonna
come into your orbit who is interested
not in making the world better but
saying this is a man with a great deal
of money and I want to get my hands on
some of it so I guess part of the
question is how does someone like
yourself learn to develop that mix
between too much trust hmm and not
enough trust I mean you know how do you
how do you split the difference between
being credulous and paranoid but I think
you have to start with the assumption
that foundations are there to be taken
advantage of it was if people will come
and apply and they'll tell you what you
want to hear and then they'll do what
they want to do so that is and I don't
think one should be angry with them for
for thinking that so you have to
certain processes like competitive
competitions so that you ask people to
to say this is the area where we are
willing to support please submit your
proposals and then we choose and of
course sometimes we choose badly but the
fact that you've got competition is is
help so my proposal for a study of the
impact of sudden unearned wealth on a
late middle-aged man probably doesn't
have much of a couple of specific
questions
where will the euro take the world
economy the euro well the euro is a
political creation and
I think it's you can't have a common
market without the common currency so it
creates greater unity in in in Europe
you then have a problem of the relation
between the two major currencies and
there there are you know possible
problems there but if you if you're
looking at the grave or the gravest
situations facing either the Anglo
American or their European American
economy the world economy
do you rank the euro problem fairly high
or is it no no I think the Euro actually
is you know it's it's in existence it
has its problems I mean all together
Europe now is in a really interesting
phase of its development in the next
couple of years some really major
decisions have to be made about the
future of Europe
what about Argentina is it gonna survive
the present financial chaos our state's
the worst of all possible worlds the is
the it's the it's a disorderly breakdown
and it's it's sort of a it's a verse
financial disaster I would say since
since the 30s really I mean it's
question collapse I had a few years ago
yes much worse yes and what for somebody
who never took economics one I'm quite
serious about this what why should we
what why should we worry about that in
other words for a lot of us we see that
in the paper
you know page one or two teen financial
as we go oh and we turn the page mmm
because I'll speak for myself I still
don't fully grasp what it could mean for
us what could it mean for us no it
doesn't mean much for us it means a lot
for them okay well I
my heart goes out to them but it's not
like it's not like that that's the
starting point
yeah and and actually we can't solve
their problem but we are a little bit
pregnant because you know because we are
involved through the IMF and so there is
if it isn't that we can just sort of
ignore it what this is what about Cuba
but it's a world tour what's your
prognosis for a post Castro area and
what should we be doing to breathe life
into this communist regime
let's amend that what should we be doing
to breathe life into what should we be
doing anything are you involved no
actually I'm not
you know I'm already suffering from
Imperial overstretch so I don't think I
can be involved in everything but you
know our position towards Cuba is
actually we treat it as an internal
political problem that is to say what
how does it affect the elections and are
basically two types of Cubans in America
there are people who had property and
have no family and people who had no
property and have family in Cuba and the
first group dominates our policy and I
think it's wrong I think we should have
we should have lifted the sanctions long
ago
will the u.s. effort to cut off the
sources of money for terrorism succeed
or fail what's the best way to succeed
in this effort we heard an awful lot
about the effort to dry up the
terrorists source of funds and that we
you know we try to engage other
countries in it can it work well I think
it can make an impact and there's a
really major effort going on and it it's
the sort of thing that needs to be done
to protect against terrorism now it's
interesting that we were opposed to the
OECD standards for international
cooperation on disclosing information
prior to September 11 the Bush
administration refused to cooperate now
they are leading the charge and there
are many other things that could be done
by greater cooperation in this field not
only about terrorism actually my my
current sort of top favorite is a
cooperation among to force or oblige the
oil companies and and natural resource
companies to disclose how much money
they pay to individual countries so for
instance Angola or Nigeria how much
money they actually pay for those
resources and you could then add it up
and you could then look at the budget
and see how much it goes into the budget
and you would find that there are
several billion dollars missing so this
is for instance one area of
international cooperation which could
make a major difference to the
prosperity of those countries there's
nothing to do with the terrorists that's
okay it's missing not because they're
funneling to terrorism just stealing it
where is that money going it's missing
it's been slowly going into the bank
accounts of the presidents and and this
is something that we could actually stop
I think the oil companies would favor it
really quite happy with it
as long as the other oil companies are
obliged to do it so this is now you know
I'm saying this is my top priority now
it's because Africa is on the agenda of
the g8 in June then there is a new
economic program for Africa and this is
missing I think adding this into it
would make the whole thing much more
effective just wrap this up by coming
home literally if you're if you feel as
strongly as you do that this is the one
country that can actually that has the
power financially to reshape these
international arrangements and therefore
to change the world for the better and
you don't like the direction that things
are going in now to what extent have you
used your resources which is a polite
word for money to influence domestic
politics do you contribute a lot of
money to candidates as little as
possible but I do I do
give whatever $2,000 to certain well
that's the hard money limits that's a
hot there are soft money's which you
still have until November 6th which are
unlimited I mean you you are involved
all over the world trying to make life
better for people and you could mean
somebody could say to you wait a second
you know if this is the country that's
going to make all the difference and
only the government's can do it why
aren't you you know why aren't you your
version of say a Rupert Murdoch you know
why aren't you starting magazines
newspapers changing the intellectual
political debate here at home and
pouring money into
candidates and groups that favor this
view so that if you change the United
States view you change the world yes
well actually I am devoting more
attention to that because I believe that
the role of the United States is so
important in the world that I think one
needs to push this a point I've been a
supporter of clean money in in elections
for instance of support the main
initiative and Arizona initiative these
are basically the forms of public
financing for the four four four four
elections and I think they're working
rather well in those and I would say
that if I saw a leader who articulated
the the my vision of the United States
being a leader of a global open society
I would really stand behind him because
I think it's really very important the
problem is I don't see such a leader I
have in the past been more of a Democrat
than a Republican so I'm not
particularly sort of involved in in
politics but I have been inclined
frankly I'm inclined to become a
moderate Republican because I think the
moderate Republicans have done more to
rein in the excesses of the Bush
administration than the Democrats well
if you guys out there have been half as
engrossed as I have this has been worth
your while this has been an absolutely
fascinating
George Soros is chairman of Soros Fund
Management and the Open Society
Institute a foundation that funds
efforts to promote democracy around the
world his book George Soros on
globalization is published by public
affairs online at public affairs box com